midnight sun is finally coming out
the book that was from edward's
perspective
right would you ever consider like a
some kind of
recut or doing that film
does that interest you at all it would
be another film which would be
fun you know be fascinating
of course you know yeah
oh aisha
this show is the best show i've seen on
quibby it is just fantastic
as a filmmaker what was the appeal to
you in exploring these kind of like
seven to ten minute episodes i love
a story like that you know a teenage
self-discovery
you know a coming-of-age story but this
one just took it to a new level
of what you discover about yourself when
you start digging deeper
and i so i love that i love the
technology aspect that was actually
married to this
idea of new technology the quibby
technology so it was
very sort of integrated the concept and
the
story and quibby and i like the idea
of having these chapters like when we
read books i love reading books and
chapters and
some of the great like non-linear books
where you start with another
chapter and you have um you know a
flashback or a
different character's point of view so
all of these combinations made me think
this is going to be an exciting
challenge
that i've never been before helena
howard is an absolute
star how did you guys i mean how did you
link up
she had starred in that sundance movie
madeline's madeline and so
when people mentioned watch this movie
and you just
almost could watch the trailer of the
movie and you see
how present she is how emotionally
you know available vulnerable so i just
loved her and of course we skyped yeah
that was back in the day of skype
we skyped you know uh so that was
and i really thought you know she's
going to bring so much to this you know
she's really fascinating and she's tough
you know and she
she won't do anything that doesn't feel
really real
you know yeah well you have you have
kind of the midas touch when it comes to
working with these
these young stars in the making i mean
evan rachel wood
oscar isaac nikki rhee kristen stewart
robert pattinson anna kendrick just to
name
a few of them do you think about how
much these guys have accomplished who
got their start working in your films
oh i mean i'm just so excited when i see
all the new
projects they're doing and and you know
everything
all everybody you just mentioned is
incredible you know like just
done so many different things and
starting businesses and
you know inspiring the world so it's
very cool
yeah if i could take a second to geek
out i do have to say that 13 is one of
my absolute favorite movies of all time
it is like probably not intended but
it's like my comfort movie like i'll
throw it on when i just like want to
watch it
oh thank you well that was so special
you know obviously evan and nikki were
only 14.
holly hunter and they just brought
everything to such an immersive
experience that
even like you say when you watch it now
it still feels like really
alive you know you have an incredible
knack of telling
stories through the eyes of of of young
women in a really great way
so what was it about this story that you
feel like gets it right
right well what i thought was so
fascinating i mean this
this young woman is trying to explore
who i
am she's keeps doing these
self-portraits kind of obsessively and
just
not quite sure she's talking to the
therapist doesn't understand what feels
off something's off in her family life
it seems like
and then when she does make that
discovery of who she self-discovery
it is more mind-blowing than
anybody's journey of self-discovery so
it took like 13
and almost put it on steroids what she
discovers you know
um tracy was trying to figure out should
i be the popular girl or the good girl
well this girl is
trying to find find something very deep
that has a darkness to it and she's
trying to
still keep the love empathy and
understanding you know and continue pick
up the pieces of her life
we were doing a lot of comic con
coverage and we were reflecting on
twilight in 2008
and how that's kind of known as like
this
tipping point where it's kind of shifted
how comic-con was
i mean do you do you reflect on that do
you think about that often
oh yes of course for me that was
absolutely
crazy you know as we everybody our whole
panel we stepped out on that stage and
people were just going
crazy and it wasn't you know yeah it was
a lot of women it wasn't all
superheroes and action it was something
different you know
and people like you know treated rob and
chris and everybody like rock
stars yeah as you can imagine i felt
like
everybody was about to faint like is
this real it was
so thrilling you know and i think it was
great to have that change you know that
women are here and you know a story
about a young woman could be
you know loved and embraced yeah and i
remember like right
around when twilight was coming out like
it wasn't like we didn't know
like i'm sure you didn't know is it is
this gonna be a hit is this gonna be
just like a kind of smaller film so was
comic-con
when you realize like oh this is a
phenomenon
we really realized it i mean it was like
a shockwave
in that auditorium you know it was
it was a shockwave but is that going to
last and even after comic con they
weren't even sure is it going to
you know will it make only 30 million
opening weekend well it made 69
million opening week so it even then
blew out the expectations
i'm curious i don't even know if you've
given us any thought but midnight sun
is finally coming out the book that was
from
edward's person would you ever consider
like a
some kind of recut or doing that
film does that interest you at all i
think the recut would be
difficult because you know we did stay a
lot more in bella's
head like we did in this with aisha's
head you know but i
so it would be another film which would
be fun you know
be fascinating of course you know
yeah rob is batman now so
moved on and kristen has done a million
beautiful projects so
you know who knows what would happen but
yeah
kristen and charlie's angels is like one
of the most gorgeous women i've ever
seen in my life and
fun oh yeah she's great she's uh
she's my favorite and then rob being
batman how did you feel when you heard
that casting
i mean i can't wait to see it because i
know he's going to just bring
layers that are fascinating you know
because he is a very fascinating person
so i'm excited about it
yeah he's going to knock it out of the
park um well thank you so much for your
time this show is just
fantastic i can't wait to
watch the rest and such an honor to talk
to you and our
new and this actress helena howard is
fantastic too i think people are going
to really
dive into her and feel a lot about her
and this
this project so i can't wait for you to
see the other episodes because it just
keeps getting better
i know i can't wait thank you so much
for your time thank you